les deux seuls problèmes vraiment j'ai
eu avec elle c'était lui faire
arriver à lui fait remettre sa jupe en
dessous du genou
et puis le faire baisser ce que sa
choucroute afin sable
son truc immense alors ça s'était dit
c'était difficile
d'imiter nom brille brille enfin il est
confiance en moi ça est ce que si je
marche 15 mètres sur les mains enfin
disons à ce que si je marche sur les
mains ce que chaque mètre que je marche
sur les masques vous l'acceptez de
baisser d'un centimètre votre coiffure
que vous savez pas marcher sur le git
alors voilà je vais faire ça
[Musique]
j'en ai fait un peu plus et ben large à
l'aise dans la choucroute
[Musique]